normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
Chris pavlovski the CEO of Rumble he
tweets I can confirm this attack has
been unprecedented and has been
happening since this weekend Rumble for
those that are just uh uh for just
tuning in would has been under a Cyber
attack and this may be related to Alex
Jones uh but look let's be real I Rumble
is really challenging the machine Alex
Jones was restored on X and it was
announced that he would appearing on
Steven Crowder's show this morning all
of a sudden Rumble is slammed Viva fry
tweeted I was planning to go live but
Rumble and locals are down apparently is
a it is a massive unprecedented attack
one that is likely politically motivated
if I have any updates I'll let everyone
know godspeed Rumble Chris pavlovski
followed up by saying I also suspect it
is political coming from activists and
our organizations who want to censor our
creators and related to j6 videos being
posted on Rumble 2024 is two weeks away
it is going to be wild when he was in I
was like you got to decentralize this
service and I I I know he knew I was
right and we also both know the the
momentous amount of effort that would
require and especially the the challenge
to to stream video from like a mesh but
I know Chris is thinking about it he's a
server Master but as long as that Rumble
thing is on local servers or centralized
on big datas man you are it is Target
Target Target and it's like when you're
a Sitting Duck man you're in you're in a
rough position as a tech company
now who's really behind these attacks
that's a question that I'm kind of
asking myself I have my clear
speculations I have a clear answer to
who would be invested in stopping these
conversations from happening but Rumble
is on the on the up and up it's becoming
a very serious Contender to one of the
biggest online media companies in the
world a monopoly on the industry that of
course abuses their power routinely and
hosts particular shows and platforms
like um that are major And when they see
a competitor coming out and and and and
doing their job better and allowing the
free market to actually speak and
represent itself holy cow that is a
danger to their business that is a
danger to their industry and um I I
wouldn't be surprised if it's the
competition saying we got to shut it
down before they take our cake it could
be uh the Russians wanting you to think
that by making you think that the enemy
of your enemy is doing something to your
like it could be it could be three deep
you know it could be someone trying to
get you to think that it's Google doing
it to rumble or getting you to think
that it's the American government doing
it to rumble to so descent but I think
the most obvious answer is it's someone
that didn't like the politics yeah
whoever it is well I think I think you
bring up a good point I think often
times we have an enemy like the CCP for
example and a lot of times we see these
cyber attacks and it gets blamed on the
CCP and and it's peculiar because even
the people that do business with the CCP
will say that you know people like Joe
Biden and and the administration and say
oh it's the CCP it's the CCP well I
wonder how many times they blame it on
these other on our enemies when really
it's them uh like you saw with the whole
balloon situation oh well it's the CCP
but for some reason we can't shoot it
down um well well we had our
reservations about that we weren't
exactly certain that that was the case
uh given what the government has done in
the past but uh I think that they do
take advantage of our enemies and they
blame it on that I think in the case of
Rumble obviously Rumble wouldn't be the
ones to blame it on a a fake enemy but I
can see like some sort of uh Story
coming out blaming it on the CCP or
something like that or maybe even Russia
but uh I mean I I I just I think as
people who are in tune with politics we
have to be careful that we don't allow
them to use our enemies as a way to as a
way to get away from their own
responsibility of the fact that they did
it because the government's obviously
never going to tell us oh we did it or
or YouTube's never going to be like we
did it you know I don't think we're ever
going to find out who who's really
responsible here and who actually did do
it it could be a lot of different people
too working in conjunction absolutely I
think about a lot of the CCP like I
although I am concerned with that
authoritarian economic you know
autocracy whatever oligarchy I guess
communist a it I don't want to like say
that's just the purest evil on Earth and
every because then it's just going to
send the US to war with them and I don't
want to do that I want to avoid that
well the same thing they did with Russia
I mean they make Putin out to look a
certain way and it's like they make him
look like he's some evil dictator but
it's like no one actually breaks down
his reasoning for what he's doing nobody
actually and it's a disservice to
ourselves because then we don't actually
understand who we're dealing with uh
whoever side you're on it's disservice
to to not understand who your supposed
supposed enemy is uh but they don't want
you to think about that because if you
did think about it and you did start
researching it you might actually
realize that they've lied to you about
who he is and who our enemies are in
general so it's they they make it out to
be like oh don't question it they're
just your enemy it's just your enemy
don't question it but there are so many
people who just don't want to be
involved in politics and want to plug
their ears and just say la la la la la
they want to live in denial and uh you
know man I think
they're the last ones off the Titanic if
they even make it off the the people who
are Imagine This you're on the Titanic
and uh hit an iceberg and you were
standing near the front of the ship and
saw it happen well you knew what to do
you knew okay bad thing just happened
for all the people who are like down in
the ballroom just having a good old time
saying we don't care we're not paying
attention those people didn't make
it there's going to be a lot of people
who don't make it right but but but at
the same time I I you know I say that
but I I think more than ever people are
are getting the opportunity to finally
speak to each other and find out what's
really going on I think there is an
opportunity to to awaken a lot of people
there are some people that still love to
have their heads in the sand and their
tickes up be laid for whoever wants to
go out there and and take it uh and
those individuals I I think more and
more now especially with bionomics
especially with the build back better
policies are seeing the real cost of
being ignorant to Politics As of course
if you ignore politics politics is not
going to ignore you and a lot of people
have been B Bamboozled have been screwed
over and now they're saying hey hold on
maybe I should be paying attention to
what's going on here because this
actually does have a real effect on my
life so in one sense yes I I do see
people kind of being blind to certain
situations but but I do see those blinds
being lifted now more than ever I assume
it's people with young children or
people that want to have young children
they have a reason to think outside the
box about the future but like older
people that are just collecting their
social security they're just like go
shut up and I want to just watch TV but
but but there's a new data that was just
released by a CNN poll Donald Trump I
think it's in Michigan has a lead of 40
points among people who did not vote in
2020 Trump's biggest gains are among
non-voters like people who didn't vote
are waking up and they're deciding I'm
voting for Trump and that's what's
giving Trump the bump good news yeah and
every time the corporate media attacks
him viciously uh unfairly he just
becomes more popular every time the
state brings more charges to him
everyone's like hey why are you doing
this to this man as of course he's
facing 750 years in jail which is
absolutely crazy the fact that a former
president of the United States could be
going to jail for multiple life
sentences that's just a new level of
craziness and and in my opinion
desperation by The Establishment that
has gone way too far but I I've talked
to a lot of people man Trump's Trump's
going to be convicted yeah now he now
the interesting thing is I could be
totally wrong why um Trump has
petitioned the Supreme Court I believe
the Supreme Court has just said they
will take up the case Trump said you
cannot criminally charge a person for
what they did as president and I believe
he is correct you the president must be
impeached first impeached then
criminally charged uh the reason for
this is war conflict crisis the people
need to say that this duly elected rep
representative is not fit because of
high crimes and misdemeanors afterwards
we can say what they do was criminal the
reason being if you could just
criminally charge a president whenever
you wanted then every state would file
criminal charges immediately against the
president because they didn't want him
to be president it it would be it would
be like a manine the Civil War once they
were after the Civil War there's uh uh
they're having elections yeah a for a
former Confederate State would just be
like uh we're criminally charging the
president with these things yeah country
would never move forward what's going to
be the reaction of of the people when he
does get indicted when he does get
arrested he was indicted he was arrested
when he does get convicted convicted and
and put in jail but there going to be
even more indictments there's probably
going to be even more charges with the
way that things are going uh but but
when he's in jail how how will the
American people respond that's a
question I think they're listening to
people like us and they're wondering
waiting for us to tell them what to do
that's like the scary part kind of in a
way is like the not the responsibility
but also like how things are hanging by
a thread right now and people need
guidance I know what they need to do
they need to buy cbw coffee the greatest
cup of coffee I'm also work out yeah
take care your point cuz Tucker was
talking about that the other day sort of
he was saying like you know I've because
of all of these indictments and
everything like I I've become a bigger
Trump supporter is what he's saying I
think a lot of Americans feel that way
and I think that would be a breaking
point for a lot of people and I don't
you know it's hard to say what they
would do per se but I think that that
would certainly be crossing the line for
a lot of people who in the past either
voted for him because they liked his
economic policies or thought he was a
better option but I think that as he
gets indicted more and more and that
that's not even my opinion this is these
are just statistics too uh more people
are supporting him openly and uh more
fervently than ever before and I think
that means something for if that does
happen what if they do throw him in jail
uh I mean that'll ultimately probably
will mean he he would die the guy's
really old and and we all know that they
would possibly do something to him in
prison right so how how old is he 78
yeah in his late 70s but it it it
doesn't even matter like they would you
know they probably kill him like they
would find some way to kill him and
that's ultimately like I think they
probably blame it on age but you know I
mean who really knows it could be that
or well Al Alex Jones Alex Jones warned
about this yeah the the risk to Trump's
life because of of of what's happening
however I do think it's also important
to consider if we win enough culturally
and shift The Narrative enough in this
country it would make the option of
going after
Trump inviable right going after Trump
with with violence only matters if they
have the power to maintain control of a
system if it becomes apparent that you
know budl light's failure Disney's
failure uh this the the the expansion of
x if this becomes so apparent that we
are going to win what happens is the
powers that be just say oh I I was
always for free speech and they'll jump
ship and quickly rush over because they
want to preserve their own lives so I
think all we have to do stay the course
build culture support uh uh daily wire
in their movie efforts uh uh support uh
shows like timcast Steven Crowder
support Jimmy door just
anti-establishment individuals buy the
best song ever go to go to the best song
ever.com buy our song pre-order it it'll
be out Friday the reason is we want to
win the culture War support a mug Club
buy coffee brand coffee from Jeremy at
the quarter ring just support all of the
parallel economy go to Public Square buy
all your products from Public Square
just hammer down all these cultural
victories and make make sure they know
the money's not there the confidence is
not there and if you take Extreme Action
you will lose there's also we are
change. shop that's also pretty good but
uh no no what t-shirts best political
shirts.com
but what I wanted to say to to kind of
add to your point they are playing a
very dangerous game it is extremely
risky and some people have even
theorized that they're trying to push
the American people over the edge that
they're trying to kind of spur a
reaction to them that will create a
problem that they're going to have a
solution for so that's also something to
kind of think about here looking at
everything else but but as you mentioned
Tim a lot of people are are really
banking and hoping that the election is
going to solve a lot of problems for the
individual it's not what will solve the
problems are people taking personal
responsibility for themselves are people
who are going to decide to vote with
their clicks their likes their views
their dollars saying hey I'm going to
support the local Farm over there I'm
not going to support Walmart I'm not
going to support big factory farming I'm
going to go get some uh you know things
like ra milk if they're good for you I'm
going to actually do some homework and
Research into the ways that we are being
poisoned into the larger biological war
that is being waged on men and women in
this country I'm going to make sure I am
the strongest best version of myself and
I don't need the system I'm not going to
feed the system I'm going to live
outside of it in my own free honest real
way that right there is a beautiful Act
of resistance I got I got a fact check
Patriot with a good fact check saying
after being convicted on impeachment
charges Tim president Trump was
impeached he was not convicted so I'll
clarify what I'm saying the argument
from Trump is that you must be impeached
and convicted then you can be criminally
indicted and criminally convicted Trump
was impeached which is effectively an
indictment the Senate voted no and then
he was not convicted so until that
happens and he is successfully convicted
at following impeachment none of this
matters thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net